futurama is undoubtedly one of the
greatest sci-fi comedies of all time but
despite its surprisingly tight and
well-thought-out timeline the series
didn't answer every question it raised
for example what became of bender's son
ben what happens to fry and leela after
the time bending events of the finale is
fry's old girlfriend michelle still
going out with the reanimated body of
paulie shore tis better to have loved
and lost nespa
the answers to all of these questions
could make for intriguing episodes ones
we'll likely never get to see and while
we can all live with a little mystery in
the year 3000 there's one lingering
question in particular that stands out
as particularly irksome what is the
other and why is she so important to the
universe's future we know who the other
is of course it's leela that's revealed
in the season 4 episode the wire fry
which is arguably one of the most
important futurama episodes ever made in
it fry learns that the accident that
landed him in the cryogenic freezing
tube and sent him to the future wasn't
actually an accident at all it was part
of a scheme by nibbler who spells
futurama's big secret during the episode
fry isn't just a doofus he's actually
the most important person in the entire
universe see because fry is his own
grandfather the former pizza delivery
boy is immune to attacks by the evil
brain spawn making him the only person
who can stop their plans for galactic
genocide in the wire fry the nibilonians
give fry a quantum interphase bomb and
send him off to fight the brain spawn
where he defeats them and saves the
entire galaxy
here we are trapped for eternity we
could sing american pie unfortunately
there's a complication as tends to be
the case with anything involving the
planet express crew and fry ends up back
in 1999 before he was frozen and sent to
the future after some time travel
shenanigans fry goes back to that
fateful moment when he became stuck in
the cryogenic unit it may seem like a
retcon but if you go back to watch the
futurama pilot you'll see nibbler's
shadow underneath where fry sat showing
how the creative team behind the sitcom
had their plan in place all along back
to season four and fry tries to stop
nibbler from sending his original body
to the year 3000. nibbler protests
however arguing that there must be
something in the future that fry thinks
is worth saving that's where the crucial
piece of dialogue comes in she must be
the other
what
[Music]
you must not give up on her fry doesn't
know what that means and we don't either
sadly it seems like we never will fox
canceled futurama after its fourth
season and while it came back from the
dead two times the writers never
bothered to explain what nibbler was
talking about given the why of fry's
important place in futurama canon
nibbler's words seem like they carry a
lot of weight or they would if they were
ever elaborated on of course in the
absence of a real explanation fans have
concocted their own theories many assume
that the nibilonians have plans for
leela that never made it to the screen
meanwhile some think that nibbler simply
meant that leela is the second most
important person in the universe as that
theory goes leela essentially saved the
galaxy by making fry care ultimately fry
decides to send his past self to the
future in the wire fry because he loves
leela as such she's indirectly
responsible for all of fry's heroics fry
is the one in the middle of things but
leela is the person who gives fry
something to fight for other fans
suggest that nibbler might be referring
to the series finale in which fry and
leela live together as a couple for
decades while everyone else around them
is stuck in time maybe it's even a star
wars reference nibbler and yoda have
some similarities after all although you
gotta hope that fry and leela aren't
secretly brother and sister whatever the
case fan theories are the only
explanations as to the other
significance that we're going to get by
all indications futurama isn't ever
coming back making this one big question
that's bound to go unanswered
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one